a situation like you know some of the
feedback you were getting some people
let it kind of shake them but i feel
like you're like super locked in right
now i heard all three records they're
crazy yeah i mean i ain't really like
i feel like [ __ ] i'm about to go gold
feel me 7500 000 copies i know a lot of
[ __ ] that don't even do that so most
people don't do that really so i just
feel like [ __ ]
it's a body of work i feel like
maybe if they didn't enjoy it it wasn't
for them that's fair i remember uh
what's the venue in hollywood i can't
think of the name but it's the stadium
yeah the palladium that nipsey sold out
i remember going to that first show you
did and when you pulled out that piano
exactly that was a moment bro yeah
appreciate that that was like i felt
like damn i'm going to remember this
[ __ ] in like 25 i remember when roddy
sold out the palladium after nipsey did
it you know said he pulled out that
piano i remember when i
did it with nip i actually ran into head
and he was like bro if i don't hear you
in the streets you suck like say some
[ __ ] like that
i was ready to look that [ __ ] ass shout
out to head man
he was telling the truth like at the end
of the day that's how i treat it too now
like if i don't hear anything in the
streets if it ain't really buzzing like
that then it ain't making no noise a
[ __ ] can believe in some [ __ ] as well
that's that's another route but when
you're in that position where you could
really change a [ __ ] life with the
situations and the plugs you have you
got to see if a [ __ ] wanted or not you
know that's real um
how many songs do you think you recorded
in the last two and a half years
countless bro i can't count like if you
is it is it more than 500 is it less
than two courses more than five it's
more than 500 yes
is it close to is it close to like 750
over that
countless i'm telling you it's countless
i don't want to give a number anything
about all he recorded his countess
because i i heard that like uh
you know that you were just recording a
lot like recording yourself at home and
[ __ ] it's a lot bro all right at the end
of the day it's like
shooting in the gym i don't look at it
like how people look at it like it's a
money thing or you gotta put music out
and all this [ __ ] bro this is my
lifestyle that's what i do my music be
my therapy a lot of times you know to
give me a to stop thinking about should
i just lay it on the wax and it's cool
like it's over i gotta think about it no
more somewhere i can listen to how i
feel
music is like therapy time slots too
where you can go back two years and
listen to yourself listen to your pitch
and where you was at and how you was
thinking and all that type of [ __ ] is
real sometimes when you're recording you
feel like you're like it's more like a
diary for you like like yo this is just
like you could say that yeah you could
say that like i like like i might not
ever put this [ __ ] out but i know it's
here like i could always say that it's
just that's what i said it's a lifestyle
bro it ain't no
like i don't make music to be like i
gotta make a hit i gotta i brought this
[ __ ] it's a lifestyle for me i just do
this [ __ ] bro it's like picasso ain't
paint like all my sale that [ __ ] for i
know he's just painting because he loves
it it's a lifestyle you engineer
yourself at the crib i can't
that's okay
what's the home setup is it just like a
uh
mbox or the uh what's the what's the
[ __ ] thing with the wheel the apollo
chris i have to tell you yeah engineer
shout out to chris he yeah he i have to
tell you because it doesn't got so
tedious at this point like it ain't like
we down there fly with a box of
you just have the studio in the box yeah
we have boxing so you could do the hotel
you can do whatever yeah we got the
whole
setup and then we recorded on the mic
and it's cool like i'll record it
outside bro i tell them [ __ ] all the
time bro recording the dumpster bro is
the c800 like your go-to vocal mic
i i i
i go through i
you know i'll be
here and there whenever i want to hear
my voice a little different i just try
to figure out different different
different vibes and see how certain mice
is warmer right certain [ __ ] sharper so
i just be playing with [ __ ] bro i just
be trying to figure it out myself it's
just it's all art it ain't no specific
way to do this [ __ ] you know what i mean
100 man yeah um
do we know like do we have any idea
any plans in terms of
an album another album
all these albums at this point bro like
it's all albums it's all music stream
it's just all albums
i'm not a like it's mixtapes yeah
whatever it's mixtape's albums and
streams it's
whatever we just put it out and i hope
the fans love it more than anything
that's really my focus in making sure
the project is cohesive you feel me just
whatever it is i just because even from
feed the streets the first one it's like
just making sure it's
it's a body and it ain't just the head
over here the leg over there the the
[ __ ] foot over there the elbow
over there is like they got to make sure
that [ __ ] is cohesive and together
of course man and i feel like um
you got plaques off each of the tapes
right the first two tapes um i don't
feed the streets too is was yeah that's
the one i got i started getting [ __ ] on
um that one
um
we got a
late at night on the last one i i mean
every every project i do my best to give
them some good music